so I think without Brad postage fix is
VP of data science you don't tell us
what bush life they spend retail thank
you my name is Brad Klingenberg I'm here
today from the data science team it's
two tricks quite excited to be here
looks like a wonderful program so thank
you for having me so today I want to
talk about personalization and retail
and I think stitch fix is a company
really at the vanguard of a
transformation across retail and there's
a broader context before I talk about
stitch facts if you look at in commerce
if you look actually in a lot of
industries the bar for compelling
personalization is really rising we've
had recommendations of course and in a
lot of different contexts that Netflix
and Spotify and I think you'll see that
happening more and more into further and
further degrees and Citrix is a
wonderful example of a company that
makes little bets on those
recommendations for our clients as a
retailer if you want to compete on
anything other than fast delivery in
price you need to offer something more
to your clients and for Citrix this
something more is convenience and
personalization but it's really becoming
a very interesting and challenging time
to be a retailer where if you want to
compete on anything other than just
getting a package there quickly and
getting it there cheaply you need to be
able to offer clients something in
addition to that and it's a general
theme data science makes it possible to
do personalization of scale and I think
stitch fix is a really interesting
example of that that provides some
directions for a lot of other industries
so today in particular I wanted to share
a couple lessons from sterics the first
being that feedback loops really help
you unlock personalization the second is
that client incentives mattered quite a
lot so for something like this to
actually work you need to make sure that
the the incentives and interests of your
clients are actually aligned with your
own and finally and that this is kind of
the larger theme that especially for us
but I think for many companies and
increasingly in the future data in
particular data science enable
personalization of scale
so before before I talk about those in
particular let me talk a little bit
about stitch fix I guess just to give
sense how many people here familiar with
stitch fix but I've heard about it
before
great so it's fun you know more and more
hands go up every time we give talks to
that that's a lot of fun so stitch fix
is a personal styling service we're an
online retailer and the way it works is
you come to us you sign up and create a
profile you tell us about your style
preferences how you like to fit you're
you're spending preferences it'll a
variety of other things that tell us
generally about the types of things that
you like and unlike a traditional
retailer you're not actually going to
our website in shopping we act truly as
a personal stylist and we'll send you
things so we pick five things that we
think you're gonna love we send them to
you and you try them on at home keep
what you like send the rest back so it's
it's a fairly simple model from the
consumer perspective the key distinction
from a lot of traditional approaches to
e-commerce is that you're not actually
picking the things that are sent to you
so we're actually picking the items we
think you're going to love and of course
we do that based on what we know about
you and you know you know you can make
requests if there's particular things
that you like but this is really a you
know a very big bet on being able to
pick things that people are going to
love
so not just you know rendering a
recommendation on a page but literally
putting it in a box paying for shipping
sending it to a client wonderful
question about our inventory so we work
with hundreds of vendors so we have a
very wide inventory we do develop our
own exclusive brands and that's a you
know very interesting aspect of our
business but we also buy a lot of
inventory from market so the basic way
that we choose things for people is this
personal styling model where as a
retailer we hold inventory we have
warehouses across the country and we you
know based on everything we know about
the client in the inventory we'll pick
things to send to the clients
and behind the scenes is actually a
two-stage process where we look at the
inventory we look at everything that we
know about it and I'll talk about the
important feedback loops of power that
everything we know about the clients
and generate the set of recommendations
in a recommendation tool for our
stylists so stitch fix has personal
stylist actually pick things for our
clients there's actual stitch tricks
employees we have thousands of them
across the country and they'll interact
with this this recommendation platform
that essentially tries to distill
everything we know about the client in
the inventory and help them make the
best decisions but ultimately everything
that we send to somebody is actually
curated by a personal stylist and so
Citrix is also interesting and that it's
a really it's a great example of art and
science working together of human and
machine collaborating a very
complementary way to pick things that
are successful for for our clients so
it's a great question so who are our
stylist so our stylists are actual
district employees they work remotely
and mostly part-time around the country
but they're actually our employees when
we train them and a lot of them stay
with us for years so it's not like a
Mechanical Turk type work force that's
actually our own employee base of
stylists that work for us so yeah so we
have we have when I started stitch
tricks I've been there will be about
five years and in June when I started
all the stylist worked in our office in
San Francisco but as we wanted to grow
the workforce now we have styles all
across the country and it works it works
quite well we have a lot of fun events
and trainings where they come in to you
know spend time in person but most of
the work they do is remote
someone doesn't buy anything forever
yes so the question is I you know so
what for clients um by anything you know
what does I mean for the business how do
we handle that so the you know the the
basic economics for the consumer so when
you order a fix you pay twenty dollars
that's a fee and if you for instance
bought nothing you know you'd be out
that twenty dollars but if it's buy
anything at all it's applied toward that
so it's only really lost if you decide
you don't like anything at all and then
of course you know it's still up to
stitch fix to make sure that you want to
keep things and that you know people who
are getting fixes are delighted by what
they have and you know will keep enough
things to make make the model work and
it turns out to work very well and of
course the core challenge of the
business is is improving the things so
we send it people so that they specific
comments you get pictures it's a
wonderful question I'll have a few
examples and a few slides down but so we
get a lot of rich feedback from our
clients so of course we get the
simplicity that they keep it or not we
get explicit feedback this is a big to
small too expensive to be inexpensive
you know did you like the style did you
not also freeform text which is which is
quite rich as well so people can say you
know I didn't really like the way it fit
on my arm or just it just wasn't for me
and in aggregate that provides you know
fascinating source of data for example
it's a great idea but not something we
currently have in the product okay so
that's the the basic overview of stitch
fix we want to return to the three
lessons I wanted to highlight today and
the first is that feedback loops really
unlock personalization and this is
related I think to some of the some of
the questions about the data that we get
back so clients tell us about themselves
in general and so when they sign up they
tell us a lot about their preferences
and you know the types of things that
they'd like to receive and so this is
you know explicit data people are
providing for us as they join the
service as we send people fixes they're
actually providing more and more data to
us so for for everything that we send
you can provide feedback along a number
of dimensions
men should not just structured feedback
which is of course particularly useful
for you know algorithmic assumption but
also freeform text which is which is
fascinating so if you're working on a
Citrix inventory team and you understand
what people are saying about a blouse
that you've purchased you can you know
look at all this text in aggregate it's
a really amazingly rich source of source
of information so our clients you know
tell us about things through what they
tell us upfront but then also through
the feedback they provide as we as we
send them send them things to me they
can fixes and of course this enables a
lot of virtuous cycles and in feedback
that helps us make things better so for
example if we send somebody a blouse and
she says well you know I like maybe I
like to style the price point was just
right it was just a little too big so we
can we can take that feedback and now we
know something about the client and when
we're trying to send her about next time
we know something about how things fit
her but in addition to that we actually
now know something about the blouse and
so if you look at the feedback that
people provide in aggregate we're
learning not only about the individual
preferences of our clients which of
course the reason that people are
compelled to provide feedback so that we
get to know them so then provide better
and better selections for them as they
stay with the service over time but if
we you know aggregate this information
over our client population we learned
about our inventory as well so if we
have a blouse that we think is you know
large and we send it to a thousand
people and nine hundred them say that
it's too small well we've learned
something about the blouse right it
might not be might not be the right size
and this is really interesting just just
to mention a little bit so of course you
know this information allows us to then
do a better job choosing who to send
that blouse to in the future so you know
it helps other clients and the service
very interestingly so we we work with
different brands we might decide you
know the splash isn't really working for
our client population we should buy less
of it we should you know avoid buying
things like it in the future and very
interestingly so we developed some of
our own inventory and so this is when
the feedback loop really gets
interesting so if you actually control
the blueprint so to speak of the of the
inventory and you're getting real
feedback you can say well you know we
think
clients would like the skirt a little
bit better if it was about an inch
longer let's just make it an inch longer
and you can take advantage of that
feedback loop to actually optimize in
this kind of evolutionary way inventory
that we carry and so we have a lot of
feedback not only to the the basic
problem of recommending things to people
successfully but also just choosing and
creating a better set of things to hold
an inventory in the in the first place
it all relies critically on that that
flow of information back from our
clients and I wanted to underscore I
think what it's easy to kind of overlook
here and that's that the incentives of
our clients really matter in enabling
this feedback loop so our clients tell
us a lot of things so the feedback I
mentioned that you know the explicit
preferences and it's important for us
that that they share it with us and if
you look at this two tricks model and
you try to apply it to more traditional
retail business often you don't have the
state up and is it that traditional
retailers just don't think they need it
no of course not they'd love to have
this information so this detailed
information about exactly who keeps
every item and the feedback that they
provide and and the reason is that it's
hard to get it because there's really
not a good reason for the for you to
tell a retailer you know this detailed
structured information it's really the
alignment between the incentives of our
clients and getting the product better
over time that makes it compelling for
them to do so for stitch fix and I think
it's you know it's really interesting if
you think about you know a typical store
you go to the mall imagine you're trying
to optimize that inventory think how
hard that problem is so what do you what
do you observe well people walk in
people walk out some things will be sold
you'll be able to say local these are my
best sellers but it's hard to say much
about who's buying it you know do they
really like the fit is so just because
it's cheap what is it that they actually
like about what they're buying and
importantly you you really don't know
anything at all about what people choose
not to buy so if people have tried
something on is that you know this would
be great if it just fit you know a
little more loosely or if it had a you
know a bolder pattern and all that data
is just you know of course invisible and
so the what we really want to enable is
for clients to give us this information
so we can plug it into those feedback
loops
to make everything better over time and
of course the reason that they do this
is not because they love stitch fix and
run us to you know altruistically wants
districts to do well it's selfish right
it's in their own interest they want
their experience to get better and
that's the client promise that we have
we want to know people better over time
to understand your style preferences and
how you like things to fit and that's
great because it aligns with our own
interest of getting to know people and
then of course you know getting to know
the broader client population as well
and so it's really the second order
benefit of your feedback you know help
stitch fix and helps other clients that
is extremely valuable to stitch fix and
it's only supported because of the fact
that there's this first order benefit to
our clients that didn't sense them and
so what it means for example is that you
know we don't have to you know have
surveys and say like oh if you give us
this feedback fool we'll give you a gift
card you know please fill out the survey
people are incented to do that just by
the the nature of the service itself
absolutely yeah so I think it is
interesting so I think here the the
incentives are aligned so that you know
everybody is using the service has a
good reason to provide useful helpful
feedback and it is quite true I think
you know some people like to share
regardless of the incentive or not and
it is amazing so I mentioned you know we
collect freeform text and it's just
people it's amazing some people are so
effusive with feedback this is just a
wonderful opportunity for them to you
know to share and you know it's really
staggering the amount of information we
we get about you know various things
that we send people but you know really
for us you know for this model to work
it relies on clients having this benefit
to themselves or they actually want to
provide this this information to us and
you know it can be fun so it doesn't
have to be like you know a tedious
survey that you fill out we have some
games you can play on facebook Messenger
where you rate things and that provides
us information and this is actually
people love this it's almost like a game
you know it really you know providing
feedback and preference stating it
doesn't have to be a chore or early
this thing and in fact this is actually
quite fun for a large subset of our
clients so the last thing that I wanted
to mention I don't think that'll be
really much of a surprise to anybody in
the room today is that data and data
science are really empowering this at
scale so if you think about stitching so
zoom out like what are we doing it's a
personal styling service and in some
ways it's actually quite old-fashioned
if you think about how you might have
you know purchase clothes you know in
the past you might have had a high-touch
experience where someone helps you pick
things and recommends things and you
know gets notes your preference over
time and that's very much the spirit of
you know what we're trying to do is
stitch facts but we want so much more we
don't want to hire you know a tailor or
stylist and you know every neighborhood
and have them serve people we want the
quality be uniformly high across all of
our clients we want to learn from this
this feedback so that we can make our
recommendations and our products better
over time
and we want to be able to iterate right
so this has never done we're always
trying to make it better and so we want
to have a platform that we can improve
over time and it's really data and data
science that make this make this
possible and so using an algorithmic
platform really really makes this you
know possible to improve over time so of
you know algorithms and things that you
can test are very easily iterated
they're they're testable so we can see
if we change our recommendation
algorithm if we change the way we think
about client sizes does it actually
improve client outcomes this is an
empirical question if we could we just
run experiments and find out and
replicable and this this is what I think
is really interesting so of course if
you think about how Citrix works its
hybrid of human decision-making in
algorithms fused together in this
complimentary way but but the fact that
we we have an algorithmic platform that
we can change you can almost think of is
it's like a human algorithm so
essentially what you put in the
interface and the information you show
to humans is almost like a feature
engineering exercise for for human
consumption how do you help stylist make
better decisions just as you might think
how could I help this algorithm or this
process create better outcomes and the
fact that we can test it so you know we
put a lot of effort in
thinking about the tools that our
stylist use and how do we help them make
better decisions and you know as soon as
we make some something better we can
roll that out to all of our stylist and
so we have this this you know in
contrast to a you know a tailor or
stylist that you know might have great
expertise but it's kind of all by
themselves we have this platform where
if we make an improvements the way
people work we can just sweep it across
our whole platform the stylist to use it
as wisely because it also take advice
from the stylish themselves because it
you might be an amazing stylist yeah
great question about our platform so we
certainly try to learn a lot from our
stylist so and I think it's it's a
fascinating human computation problem to
think about how to optimize its joint
system of human judgment which is very
complementary to the type of algorithmic
decisions that we make and so we do get
a lot of data about you know what do our
stylist think and it's very interesting
of course to think when did the machines
and the humans have differences of
opinion and what what do you do in those
situations so there's a fascinating set
of problems stickiness between customers
and stylist or whatever stylist it's a
great question so we actually have a
whole algorithmic platform devoted to
pairing clients and stylist and
certainly like if you like your stylist
and have a good experience you know it's
generally the good thing to keep keep
them together you know but for it also
varies by client some clients care a lot
about that they really want to have a
relationship you can leave a note for
your stylist and they leave a note when
they send you a shipment so you can kind
of develop you know if you know a
relationship around that other clients
now we're just more transactional like
hey I just want some shirts you know I
don't really you know what I have a you
know a detailed exchange with anybody
and actually part of the product is you
know not having to do that so I think it
varies client to client what what they
prefer
so it's a great question so there's I
you know hundreds of decisions they go
into you know creating a platform like
this and the actual algorithms that run
on it and we're constantly testing them
so wherever possible we run you know
randomized experiments in systems where
that's not possible we think really hard
about whether there might be proxies or
you know kind of pseudo experiments that
we can run but for for it's a general
rule you know the gold standard for us
is on randomized controlled experiment
so a wonderful question and a really
interesting one what is the value of the
stylist what is the value of the
algorithm could we decompose them could
we run an experiment and figure out what
was the contribution from each and I'd
say in I think we have a good idea of
where Silas and algorithms contribute we
we don't ever send fixes to people where
there's not a stylist though because
it's we have a commitment to you making
every fix great and then that involves
both humans and machines so just to wrap
up I wanted to mention one other thing
which at which i think is interesting so
stitch fix of course is a retailer and I
think there's a lot of interesting
lessons here about the future of
personalization and in the in the bar
for greater personalization that we'll
see across many industries I think
there's also an interesting lesson if
you look at what's districts does so we
have a team of almost 80 people working
in data science and platform engineering
it's it's a large team and our business
we you know we don't sell data we're not
in the data science data we don't is not
data but data is absolutely our business
and what what we do internally I've
mentioned a few things about managing
inventory improving recommendations the
data science is actually broadly engaged
with virtually every aspect of our
business from from marketing to all
aspects of managing our inventory and
logistics and so we have data scientist
working on virtually all of these
problems I think this is a trend that
we'll see more and more over time
data science is evolving from kind of a
back office you know research resource
for a for an organization or you might
say I'd like you to develop the specific
algorithm or solve that solve a very
particular supervised machine learning
problem and at Citrix we do those things
of course and they're important but I
think we're much more broadly engaged
with the business and work on things you
know what is the business optimizing how
do we measure if the businesses is
succeeding how she would make trade-offs
how should you know business make
decisions with uncertainty and these are
all questions that quantitative folks
and data scientists are very well
equipped to answer and I think it is a
little bit different from from how a lot
of businesses run traditionally where
you have you know kind of a like a
backroom resource of technical people
and I think so essentially I think
there's going to be a broader theme
across many industries of data
scientists breaking out of the lab and
actually doing business and I think in
addition to the interesting business
model the Citrix assets a great example
of a place where data Sciences a is a
first-class partner in running the
business and with that I think we're
just about on time so thank you for
having me in fact actually everything
I'm wearing today is two tricks it's a
wonderful question so one thing that's
very interesting so these are actually
slightly stretchy jeans I would never in
my life have sought them out but I'll
tell you I'm never gonna go back to
normal jeans how do you figure out take
this customer - yeah it's a great
question I think despite you know
working in Citrix and absolutely loving
the businesses you might guess you know
I'm not particularly fashionable I think
stitch fix has helped me in that regard
so I think I I enjoy having you know
things suggested for me being able to
kind of get
doubt of what I would select for myself
which would be maybe an unending series
of blue button shirts asymmetry you of
your only question about white is
traditional retail not that isn't like
my guess would be that you could
optimize your infantry a machine
learning stuff on the basis of let's say
1% of the users who are and then most
users could figure out what they want
just by looking at some of the inventory
so in other words small amount of data
each wave rather than this massive data
exercise do you is that your experience
that most of your learning comes from a
few indicative people rather than their
massive it it's a wonderful question so
I think or learning about inventory you
could certainly try to do some sort of
sampling where if you you know got
feedback from a set of people who were
near the decision boundaries on
different things you could learn about
managing inventory without getting
feedback from everybody I think so I
think you could probably you know do
with some down sampling there for the
recommendation probable I do think is
actually quite important to have the
preferences of you know each person
individually and aspiration obstetrics
is really to know everybody personally
and there I think it's important you
know for people to tell us oh this is
too big for me or I found this too
expensive so that we can do better
recommending things over time thank you
[Applause]
so we you know for contrasting other
view so Citrix is everything is in the
cloud or in